le 29 octobre 1921 la carte famille
nombreuse voit le jour c'est une idée de
l'état elle permet aux familles de plus
de trois enfants de voyager avec la sncf
à prix réduit les membres d'une famille
nombreuse bénéficient d'une réduction de
30% pour une famille de trois enfants de
moins de 18 ans et 75 % pour une famille
de six enfants les années passent la
carte évolue peu à la fin des années 90
1,5 million de bénéficiaires profitent
de ces ristournes dans les transports
c'est un succès quand on voyage en
famille c'est quand même appréciable où
son père pauli ticket de train mais les
choses se compliquent en 1998 les
frontaliers européens se sentent lésés
et porte plainte devant la commission
européenne n'aurait l'occasion pour
partie en retrait ce qui serait moins
fatigant pour la famille ce conte
voiture c'est pas toujours évident mais
vu le prix on y renonce à chaque fois
pour l'union européenne cette carte est
un avantage commercial est une
infraction aux traités communautaires
elles demandent sa suppression
du côté des usagers français c'est la
consternation moi j'essaie milliers pour
la maintenir et ô combien ils devraient
peut-être l'étendre à tout l'europe
plutôt que de la supprimer
un système discriminatoire pour l'europe
mais une prestation sociale pour la
france en effet l'état subventionne des
tarifs sociaux de la sncf la carte est
donc inattaquables les réductions
famille nombreuse correspondent à des
éléments de politique familiale domaine
réservé et souverain de chaque état par
conséquent la commission européenne n'a
pas compétence pour régir ce domaine
finalement bruxelles en reste là mais en
2008 nouvelles menaces la crise
économique plombe le budget de l'état à
l'heure des économies le gouvernement
annonce la fin du versement de sa
subvention annuelle aux tarifs sociaux
de la sncf une subvention qui s'élève à
70 millions d'euros cette cape dans
l'état actuel des choses va certainement
disparaître en pleine crise 'l'annonce
passe mal une polémique éclate le
premier ministre renvoie la balle à la
sncf dumas projet de suppression
j'aimerais simplement c'est à la sncf
désormais quitte une entreprise
comme les autres de mettre en oeuvre cet
autre familiale et c'est elle qui le
font
la sncf devrait donc combler le trou
laissé par l'état nouvelle levée de
boucliers après 48 heures d'imbroglio le
gouvernement recule la carte famille
nombreuse et pérenniser concernant son
financement ce restera à financement
assuré par l'état
aujourd'hui 1,2 million de personnes
bénéficient toujours des réductions de
la carte famille nombreuse un avantage
qui pourrait cependant être remis en
cause lors de l'ouverture à la
concurrence du transport ferroviaire en
[Musique]